in 1986 I was part of a delegation of US
senators that went to moscow to meet
with then new young leader Mikhail
Gorbachev now the way we stopped at a
couple of other Eastern European
countries and I asked everybody we
talked with do you believe that you can
give people free choice and Economic
Affairs and deny it to them in political
affairs their answer was yes well they
weren't right in those cases that
doesn't mean the Chinese can't do it but
in my view is very difficult
particularly with modern communications
and the desire for people to become
involved not just in their communities
but in a broader society and so I think
it's very tough we'll see what happens
in China but and I don't think I'll live
to see it but you might that I i think
if you open up the economy and you give
people free choice and Economic Affairs
inevitably some kind of choice in in
political affairs becomes essential I
think the reason the economy is now so
important to the Chinese leadership is
that most governments in history derived
their legitimacy from divine right that
was monarchs and to a lesser extent
dictatorships and in the 20th century
ideologies we believe in our system that
the only legitimate the only appropriate
source of legitimacy for any government
is a consent of the government well the
the ideologies of communism is a failure
I once wrote a book on the the triumph
of democracy in the fall of communism it
to me it's obvious in retrospect that
was doomed to failure from the beginning
nobody I don't think anybody believes in
it anymore including the Chinese they're
about as entrepreneurial as you can get
so how does the government hang on a
power a hang on the pile by delivering
economic
growth for over a decade maybe more
spectacular economic growth and I think
that they are invested in growth because
it is the sole remaining source of their
legitimacy so I think they have to
continue to promote economic growth
which means joining the World Trade
Organization trade with the United
States buying American bonds all the
rest of it and I think inevitably that
will open them up in their political
processes
no one can look at human history and say
war is impossible on the other hand it's
surely not inevitable why why can't we
have a conflict of economic competition
of ideas we are a different country from
Canada and Mexico and yet you don't ask
me whether war with Canada or Mexico is
inevitable even though they're right
next to us and nobody asks we're a
different country from France and
Germany and Britain nobody thinks that a
war there isn't it but why should a war
be inevitable with China I don't believe
it is I think I don't remember where i
read this but Truman was once asked
about that aspect of communism that
stated or suggested that human affairs
are decided by large impersonal economic
events and Truman's answer was men make
history not the other way around and of
course the politically correct answer
today would be men and women make
history but the reality is that what
happens to the United States and China
will be decided by Americans and Chinese
and it is not inevitable that the via
conflict and we ought not to get
ourselves caught into those terms with
suggests that conflict is inevitable the
one conviction I have coming out of
northern island is there at there's no
such thing as a conflict that is
inevitable or can't be ended convicts
are created conducted and sustained by
human beings they can be ended by human
beings and and I don't think you ought
to begin with the mindset of conflict
what you should begin with is a mindset
of how can we create a circumstance in
which both can exist competing
economically and the world of ideas and
so forth without conflict I think it's
not only possible but highly feasible
although as I said if you look at
history which is filled with wars and
also filled with tremendous repetitive
errors in judgment by political leaders
that led to country